這4.5兆美元
就這麼平白消失了
2025年的氣候大會上
德國環境組織德國看守
發表了最新的《氣候風險指數》
他們統計1995到2024年
這30年間
全球發生的極端天氣事件
總共有9,700次
造成83萬人死亡
經濟損失超過4.5兆美元
欸等一下
誰關我燈
地球要完了
關燈愛地球啊
馬斯克還不能帶我們去火星啊
欸 不是
你這樣好像地球變熱
是因為我冷氣開太強
燈開太亮
但老實說
這鍋不該我背
你想想
如果房間或辦公室
有大片落地窗
光照充足
在照明的電費上
自然就可以省一些下來
但相對的
陽光帶來了熱量
冷氣自然就要開得強一些
也就是說房子的設計
從源頭影響了一棟房子需要耗多少電
而很多人可能沒想到的是
我們睡的房子
早在住進去之前
就已經產生碳排了
裡面還有一部分的碳排
是靠省電這種小動作
沒辦法減少的
建材的製造、建物的施工
本身就是個會影響環境
產生碳排的過程
這建築的存在
是要讓我們有安心生存的空間
是我們與外界之間的
唯一一道屏障
但如果建築產生的碳排
會威脅到我們的安全與荷包
那就太得不償失了
現在
我們就一起來看
科學能不能解決這個
迫在眉睫的現實問題
欸等一下
這裡好暗我好熱
可以先把燈打開嗎
房子排碳 這是事實
根據我國環境部的數據
2023年台灣排放的溫室氣體中
有20.65%來自建築
但別搞錯了
碳排最多的不是蓋房子本身
而是使用房子這個過程
你想 房子蓋好就蓋好了
施工、使用建材就那麼幾年
但你每天在裡面開燈、吹冷氣
一住就是四五十年
我們的活動
才是建築不斷排碳的主因
根據國際能源總署IEA的統計數據
全球有37%的碳排來自建築
其中embodied carbon蘊含碳排
也就是施工、建築材料的碳排
只佔了9%
operational carbon
也就是開燈、開冷氣、開電器
這些的使用碳排
佔了28%
足足是蘊含碳排的三倍
其中
碳排最大宗的就是空調系統
在空調開得兇的建築
甚至可以佔到整棟建築
四成到五成的碳排
好啦不廢話了
誰不知道開冷氣很耗電啊
但要整天不開冷氣
臣妾真的做不到啊
所以不是要我們耐熱救地球
省電也要用聰明的方法
空調系統最大的問題來自換氣
雖然你我家裡的冷氣都採用分離式
空氣都在室內循環
沒有換氣問題
但在公共場合
尤其是商辦、醫院、學校、百貨
因為二氧化碳、甲醛
和揮發性有機物等污染物容易累積
必須進行換氣
只是呢
這換氣會把好不容易冷卻乾燥的空氣排掉
再引入室外高溫高濕的空氣
空調又要重來一次冷卻加除濕
造成巨大浪費
有沒有辦法可以換氣
但進來的空氣一樣又乾又冷呢
解決方法就是改用全熱交換器（ERV）
全熱交換器一樣有進氣道與排氣道
但在兩個通道之間
是一張特殊的交換膜
這張薄膜的材質有兩大類
一種是用纖維素膜加上吸濕劑
例如氯化鋰
另一種是磺化聚合物等
高分子聚合物製成的薄膜
表面有著大量磺酸基、羥基
這種的親水基團
不管是哪一種
都有一樣的三個特點
結構緻密但非常薄和非常親水
結構緻密呢
可以阻擋空氣輕易穿牆而過
非常薄可以讓熱傳導加速
方便熱量的交換
非常親水呢
可以在其他空氣分子
都無法通過的前提下
只讓水氣成為例外
水氣會被親水官能基捕捉
溶解進薄膜
接著穿透到膜的另一邊
再蒸散到空氣中
也就是說
最後能穿過膜的
只有熱量和水氣
當我們需要排掉廢氣
引入外面的空氣
兩股空氣會進到同一個空間
只是中間有一個交換膜隔開彼此
這時候室外空氣的熱量與水氣
會穿透交換膜
擴散到排氣一側
這樣進來的空氣就被預冷和除濕了
在台灣夏季這種高濕熱的氣候下
熱交換效率能高達70%～90%
濕氣回收效率高達60%～75%
大幅降低了空調主機的負擔
還有啊
公共場合空氣品質的標準
是二氧化碳的濃度
為了避免沒人時
空調還在拼命換氣
還要導入可以依照二氧化碳即時監測數據
調整進氣量的變風量系統
光是引入變頻控制
就能節省34%的冷卻能耗
美國帝國大廈這棟90年老建築
光是引入變風量系統
每年電費就減少了15.9%
將近280萬美元
沒錯
節能不只是愛地球的口號
省多少電
最有感的就是你我的電費帳單
我們不一定要犧牲生活品質
但要聰明節電
為了量化這些設計
到底能幫我們被動減多少電
內政部建研所訂出了
建築能效標示BERS
裏頭寫得很清楚
一棟建築的使用碳排中
可以分為建築外殼、空調、照明
電梯、熱水器等各項指標
它鎖定的不是電器
而是一棟建築物中最耗能
而且最不可避免的幾大系統
這些系統掌控了一棟建築物
約90%的能源消耗
為了一眼就看懂
BERS將這些複雜的計算結果
轉化為1到7級的標示
如果拿到50到60分算是合格
列為第四級
而1到3級則是超優良的前段班
如果你能讓建築能效
比基準值節省50%以上
就能拿到1+級近零碳建築的最高榮譽
BERS就像是房子的健康檢查表
下次你買房子或租房時
只要看這個標示
就能知道這棟建築物
會讓你的電費帳單變多還是少了
但到這裡還沒完
問題還有一大半呢
一棟建築物在還沒接上電源
還沒住進半個人之前
它可能已經因為水泥、鋼筋的生產與施工
預支了其生命週期中
極高比例的碳排放
這就是所謂的蘊含碳排
雖然剛才說蘊含碳排
只有使用碳排的三分之一
但你想想
我們花了許多力氣在節能上
就代表使用碳排這個分子會不斷下降
蓋房子本身的碳排比例暴增
最後甚至可能佔到
生命週期的50%以上
可是
要減少建築的碳排
我們總不能真的偷工減料
或是強硬地縮短施工時間吧
但
只要改變房子的蓋法
就會有完全不同的結果
首先
當我們進入施工現場
我們面臨的是廢棄物問題
傳統的鋼筋混凝土施工常使用木模板
平均用個6次就爛掉了
最後多半送進焚化爐
這就像我們買了一個便當
雖然很愛惜便當裡的食物
但每次買一個便當
卻要消耗一個便當盒
系統模板就是解決問題的環保便當盒
它的材料是鋁合金
雖然鋁的初始製造碳排高
但它就像環保餐具一樣
可以重複使用超過100次
而且鋁合金報廢後可回爐重鑄
具備極高的循環經濟價值
以台灣國網中心雲端機房為例
改用鋁模後呢
整體減少了約63.3%的碳排放啊
證明這確實是有效的減碳策略
第二種方式是徹底改變
建造一棟建築的方法
我們蓋一棟建築最常見的辦法
就是把原料都運到現場
然後再照著設計圖從無到有完成工程
這就像是在露天的地方辦桌（pān-toh）
現場呢 會受到溫度是否下雨影響
還考驗現場師傅跟徒弟的功力
要知道
混凝土的強度取決於水灰比
如果雨水混入未乾的混凝土中
會直接改變配方比例
那水分過多呢
會導致混凝土的強度大幅下降
甚至產生裂縫
而氣溫的高低也會影響水分乾燥的速度
還有啊
灌漿時需要工人手持震動機
將混凝土中的空氣排出
如果震太久石頭會沉到底下
漿浮在上面
導致混凝土析離
結構強度不均
如果震不夠
牆壁裡面容易有空洞
鋼筋裸露、鏽蝕
這些失誤會造成部分工程需要打掉重來
又或是縮短建築物的壽命
需要增加施工的次數
最後
考量現場澆置
容易有灑出、管內殘留啊或計算誤差
工地通常會多叫5%～10%的混凝土
以防不足
那這些多餘的混凝土呢
最後往往變成廢棄物
我這並不是要懷疑現場師傅的功力
而是現場變數真的太多了
天氣的變化、複雜的設計圖
艱難的施作環境
唉 挑戰實在太多了
那
把現場辦桌（pān-toh）改成中央廚房出菜
不就能確保品質穩定也減少出現殘料嗎
這就是預鑄工法
它將工地現場的混亂
轉移到工廠的精密流水線
在工廠環境下
電腦能精準控制
每一克混凝土與鋼筋的用量
大幅減少廢料
簡單來說
預鑄工法就是將所有的構件
像是柱子、梁、外牆、樓梯
全部移到專門的預鑄工廠進行
當構件在工廠做好後
會被卡車運送到工地現場
傳統工法靠濕濕的混凝土黏在一起
預鑄工法則是用機械式接合
或特殊的套筒灌漿
這就像組裝模型一樣
透過卡榫和螺絲將結構鎖死
2025年台北啟用的社會住宅萬華安居
還有預計2026年完工
新竹的中雅安居
就都是採用預鑄工法來施工
外牆和樓板都先採用模組化設計
先在工廠生產
再運到工地現場組裝
取代現場灌漿、綁鋼筋等傳統工法
除了施工當下更方便
模組化還創造了一個優勢
傳統鋼筋混凝土建築在拆除時
往往只能透過重型機具破壞性拆除
造成鋼筋與混凝土分離困難
回收成本高且耗能
預鑄構件常採用乾式或機械式接合
這使得建築物在壽命結束時
構件可以像樂高積木一樣被逆向拆解
2024年第二屆國際綠色建築
研討會上的一篇報告顯示
預鑄工法平均能比傳統現場澆置
在拆除階段的碳排降低了11.31%
最後
當一切都工業化了
那工業最擅長的製程優化就來了
首先
我們要找到能細部計算建築碳排的方法
這部分黃仁勳已經告訴我們答案了
要解決物理世界的問題
數位孿生就是現今最聰明有效的辦法
在建築學中
這個數位孿生叫做建築資訊模型BIM
它可不只是個3D繪圖軟體啊
而是把材料密度碳排係數等非幾何資訊
和3D建模合併在一起的工具
有了BIM
現在建築師和土木學家
只要動動手指
就能算出最佳的建築結構
例如僅僅是改變柱子的距離
就能減少碳排放
節省柱子數量、拉大柱子間距
也太危險了吧
不不不
正好相反
我們要減少柱子間的間距
事情是這樣的
當柱子的跨距增加
中間的橫梁承受重量時
就更可能向下彎曲
這種彎曲程度稱為撓度
在結構物理學中
撓度與跨距（Span, L）的4次方成正比
也就是如果建築師將柱子的距離
從6公尺拉大到12公尺變成兩倍好了
那這根梁呢
會下垂16倍
工程師當然不能讓梁下垂那麼多
唯一的解法是大幅增加
梁的斷面慣性矩（Moment of Inertia, I）
簡單來說就是要把梁做得更粗
那現實中我們不會那麼輕易改變柱的數量
但因為撓度與跨距4次成正比這個原因
把柱盡量做到等距寬
就能降低整棟建築物的碳排放了
為了正確評估建築本身的碳排
內政部推出另一個重要指標
LEBR低蘊含碳建築評估系統
這個系統針對建築物生命週期
進行碳排計算
這包含製造運輸、施工
更新修繕及拆除廢棄等四階段
所以為了更精準掌握這些數據
內政部建築研究所開發了BIM-LEBR
顧名思義就是結合了BIM
和低蘊含碳建築評估系統LEBR
這個程式呢 會自動分析模型
即時對應碳排係數
建築師在調整牆體厚度
或是柱子位置的瞬間
系統就能自動計算出整棟大樓
從建造到拆除的生命週期碳排
讓設計與減碳評估達到同步
例如
根據內政部建築研究所的實際案例分析
高雄某座高層集合住宅
在設計初期發現碳排過高
全生命週期減碳率是-16%
所謂全生命週期減碳率CFR
指的是與標準基線比較後
計算出的減碳百分比
那正越多呢
代表減碳越多
這負的呢
就代表該加強了
建築師於是利用這套系統
將原本忽大忽小的柱距
調整為均勻跨距
結果減碳率就從-16%
大幅改善到-8%
直接讓建築物的LEBR等級提升了一級
為了落實淨零碳建築路徑
讓2050年所有建築節能50%的目標
能順利達成不只是口號
建研所推行的兩種標示制度
BERS和LEBR
參照國際以情境模擬方法學
來進行建築物全生命週期碳足跡評估
透過科學的方法
同時對使用碳排和蘊含碳排出擊
不放過任何能拯救我們自己的機會
尤其過去啊
我們很難掌握到的碳排細節
有了科技的介入
才能幫助我們找到癥結點
並對症下藥
你有沒有看過哪棟建築物
用聰明的方法幫自己超級省電呢
留言告訴我們吧
你可以先點這裡複習
為什麼煙囪能幫你家省電
也可以點這裡
了解超耗能的半導體產業
真的能節電嗎
記得訂閱PanSci泛科學頻道
開啟小鈴鐺加入我們的頻道會員
鎖定更多精彩的科學新知、科學議題
我們下次再見